this is already so cool
um hello everyone i wanted to play neon
white which is a game that was featured
in the summer game fest showcase
um as like coming out very soon i think
it came out a few days ago and i thought
that it looked really really stylish in
the conference but wasn't entirely sold
on the gameplay and i just opened up
this menu and i was like damn dude this
looks sick so
we're gonna check out probably the first
half an hour maybe hour make myself
smaller
and i might need to move my webcam at
some point in case i'm covering anything
but it's my first time playing
thought i would share it with you all
i don't really know what to expect other
than style
which is always exciting
should have known it was gonna end this
way god's sick sense of humor or
something people like me you don't get
second chances
but
if i did i swear i'd do it right
everybody's
dead and i don't think it's like a
visual novel
huh
i swear i was just in the middle of
something can't remember a thing though
where the heck am i hmm
do i
know these people interesting
i wonder why that the f is up in the
corner
who was that hot chick that just what
was the cortana
for you've arrived in glorious heaven
what oh i died
we are the believers agents of god
angels as it were and you dead mortals
are what we refer to as neons
sinners the god is judged most
unfavorably oh
wait am i meant to be in
hell but fred nod for we have granted
you an opportunity for salvation
annual competition
maybe move this like here just to make
sure that we okay during these 10 days
you neons will use your villainous
talents to annihilate the demons
invading our cool premise kind of
getting um
a danganronpa sort of vibes
not that it's about a mystery is this
for real hey guess what you died and god
thinks you suck go kill some crap
very edgy
you will each receive a soul card
containing a weapon befitting your past
[Music]
katana
attack it cannot be discarded the
attached note reads according to our
records white's ideal weapon is a
totally sick samurai sword okay listen
the dialogue's a little bit extra
the most
common
ultimate reward
god's forgiveness and your very own
place in heaven
seems like a terrible idea but okay but
first there's some housekeeping
oh they just threw a mosque on me
just like that it will now be known as
beyond white
do not forget you are here in heaven as
guests
these masks contain an explosive that we
won't hesitate
this is such a dark premise this is
anime as [ __ ] please refrain from
removing them unless of course you'd
prefer to
go out in flames
curious what the combat's gonna be like
i guess lowly sinners shouldn't expect
red carpet treatment
but heaven kind of seems like a racket
and yet
forgiveness
is strangely compelling to me
like every inch of my body is calling
out for it
it's almost painful
exactly did i used to be oh memories are
all wiped up here
interesting now then go forth catch your
boats at the glass port and kill every
demon you find
we'll be counting
he reminds me of james from the pokemon
anime
all right
demons soul cards
no sweat memories might be hazy but i
don't need a tutorial on how to kick ass
i might they are gonna do a tutorial
right yeah very good ready for the
fourth wall
i have to stop recording youtube videos
at the end of the day what else am i
supposed to do i have a job i'm so tired
okay
[Music]
that all makes sense yeah familiar with
with all of this
no reflection
oh am i drowning
no
i don't think so i think that this is
i'm just walking on this right
the movement's very fast
oh what's this
another card
oh
[Music]
pretty simple platforming
okay
oh next i didn't know i was supposed to
be freezing
good to know
gifts findable
okay
nitro rifle andy cortez out here look at
this look at this nerd 18 seconds
he had to replay that come on now i
didn't even i didn't even know
okay so i guess move quickly
is the goal
oh there's demons here i'm excited
cool okay yeah great
fire with current god so close with key
okay
let me add them
those are demons maybe
oh wow that's okay yeah good
okay
let's keep it going
[Music]
i guess this probably has a lot of uh
replayability then
[ __ ] off andy eight seconds you piece of
[ __ ]
all right
i think i can probably move the camera
back down here for now too
oh you are supposed to speed run
there's an f
to
uh
auto restart so i guess that's like an
important component
[Music]
i would like to see how the katana
actually works at some point though
damn it
it's it's fine i just i don't feel like
i'm trying to be a pro gamer yet i'm
still learning this is still literally
the tutorial it's fine it's fine
[Music]
nine seconds
[Music]
this billy should be here billy that
made small sense
nine seconds
how is that even
possible he learned some things and you
know
not too shabby
i must have been a real hardcore guy
yo white bro it's me yellow
it has been a minute man it's like
it's a very interesting obviously
premise art style but then the gameplay
is like uh
it's not mirror's edge but in terms of
you needing to have speed
fps mirrors edge kind of like again it's
not that complex maybe it gets that
which is a very unique
game
i like the music this guy
even with a mask on i recognize him from
earlier until i know him
but just vaguely holy crap you got the
freaking anime sword i thought for sure
you'd get one of those little guns like
the uh what's it called like gnomes use
uh
gnomes
just messenger
i know you're a badass so why the hell
does an idiot like this seem to remember
me perfectly okay man no actually
i uh
seem to be missing my memories
you fill me in what for real we rode
together for years bro got up to some
crazy i don't really see these two dudes
hanging out to be honest you were my
sass game man the darkness to my light
[Music]
is that an original reference
did he just make a naruto reference
which weebs are responsible for this
game you know i saved your life once
took a bullet for you dude really yeah
i'm just missing
yeah
all right seriously dude we should team
up just like old times i can save you
for real from those like i guess i would
like to learn about who the other colors
are
and what their roles are like does this
end up being a kind of elimination time
competition yeah um
appreciate the offer but no thanks i
work alone i could be like pow and you
could be like
sure
just skip this no i'm just skipping this
dialogue i will not have anything to do
with any of this
elevate soul cod fires like a handgun
trick is a second jump okay oh yeah
[Music]
nope that's not how i thought it would
work
[Music]
i expected to
hang on a minute hang on a minute
[Music]
i'm unclear on how it's supposed to um
oh it's gone now
give it back
okay how how
[Music]
it doesn't auto double jump
use the card no that's just
i'm not sure can i break anything else
though
okay
we can restart
oh yeah
[Music]
oh it is okay so it's and just
got it it burns the pot immediately i
guess
interesting
so i wonder if like the way that um ooh
okay
if andy was getting through it earlier
if you have like a card like that in an
earlier level
so you can just jump across everything
maybe
that was a very slow one it's fine don't
worry about it
oh you can only hold two different
clouds at any time good to know good to
know
i still haven't even used my katana it's
about time let's do it
oh okay it's slow
oh that was cool
um
oh it's gotta be over here
now it's a problem though
any more cards anywhere anybody
or if i just jump to this one no okay
i think i wasted a card
big fan of this music
that was written i helped that too
getting hit oh my gosh
[Music]
balloon demons jump oh
that's neat
[Music]
i just assumed that that chain would let
me glide on it stupidly okay
[Music]
it thinks i'm stuck because i used the
card when i wasn't supposed to and it is
not wrong okay
[Music]
i think from
this one there oh [ __ ] i wasn't supposed
to shoot them that was my bad
[Music]
ah
dip it
also shift make me sprint and i've just
not been pressing it i think it does you
know
well maybe not
it's probably got multiple routes too
right
it feels really smooth didn't even break
a sweat
oh it was my first goal
level hint
huh
okay well
i sort of want to replay it for this
for the hint maybe let's just to see
what that is in terms of people
or if it even does anything
don't worry about
one more it
i'm not seeing anything
here
oh okay hang on oh
oh okay okay i see
so you have to get gold
[Music]
i mean i guess you could just figure
those shortcuts out yourself but
[Music]
oh
oh i left a demon
oh no
this guy i still have to kill him
you jerk okay let's do it almost
i'm gonna make sure i show it
i'm gonna make sure i still
shoot him
very stylish guys i'm the best i got an
achievement
global leaderboard damn okay
i could do it if i wanted to but i'm
fine
i don't you know i'm good
is that
the old girl i saw from earlier girl
all right i would like to see her oh she
hot she hot she fought
there was this huge demon chasing after
me
looks like i lost it you'd protect me if
it came back though yes
i would die for you sorry i got a boat
to catch
you're on your own kid gosh he can't see
the setup because of the mask
you know how i feel about being called
kid white i actually don't remember
amnesia
side effect of dying it seems
seriously you're not alone
i've lost some memories too like
i can't even remember how to use a gun
which makes this whole situation extra
scary not ideal won't you at least show
me how i don't know
i should probably get going you wouldn't
really abandon a cute girl like me would
you listen i'm not a cute girl but i'm
pretty sure that doesn't work in real
life i know you don't remember but you
were once a great teacher
mr white
i
i was
well
so i guess if you want to you can just
skip all this that would be what f does
right arm's extended
but not locked sorry but got a webcam
back up for the dialogue yeah
but keep it steady
you should use both hands and fill any
open spaces on the grip with your
fingers oh
there's something cold hard metal in my
hands
that hint of danger
anyway oh my god
i think you just got seduced bro
and for nothing now she's just leaving
you know it's like it's violet don't go
forgetting this time
she cute
[Music]
okay
okay i did that strangely but i still
did it
three or five bombs will also destroy
the batteries
oh that will be speeding things up okay
let's keep it going i think that one's
an easy gold so i'm just gonna go for it
except that i didn't jump
i like this song here jerk up dab dot
dot whatever it is i'm into it
oh maybe that wasn't even gold whatever
i'll take it
i think it was still silver it's fine
[Music]
i i'm missing how to climb these huh
somehow
that's it
it
gotcha
jumping before the explosion okay so
cool
oops
oh you could go up there
i saw that little
sneaky hiding spot and then missed this
card
yeah this one would be uh
a fun speed run i think because you
could probably skip like a lot a lot of
the level ooh where am i going
[Music]
[Music]
i'll take it
this game is really interesting i think
what we'll do
um is finish this mission probably
which like by the looks of the thing on
the top here we're getting
i have no cogs
ah
did i throw the card away by accident
or is it because i use the ability
[Music]
shouldn't waste both my cards there but
i had a fun time so i'll take it okay
let's keep it going
[Music]
i looked at two different contacts at a
time excluding
all right it's the last one
a lot of demons here apparently
should have gotten that caught huh
[Music]
is that the boat
[Music]
very slow way to do that
oh
i have to get those yellow
[Music]
yeah i feel like this game's gonna get
pretty intricate
honestly
nice
oh this is red
[Music]
and this is gonna be the boat
yeah there's plenty more opportunity to
use um
purples there in ways that could have
been super exciting
complete mission let's do it
this is getting too easy
i don't know i had a lot of room for
improvement dude behind you huh
whoa
demon zero red 100.
long time no see white
[Music]
i recognize her from before
this girl is you're staring
click say something cool white that is
a massive rifle
wanna taste
okay that's okay very good
seriously she literally has a finger on
the trigger that's really bad gun
control um wow
relax i just like to see you sweat in
that case you should watch me wipe the
floor with demons sometime uh i'll pass
i've seen a lifetime of that kind of
thing
you know
this is actually that's gonna be a
dating sim as well
in the competition i mean
makes me wonder do you think this will
end for us the way it did in life see
i'd love to answer that but
i woke up with no memories of life you
don't need to keep telling us they don't
recognize you players know it's just the
details are fuzzy so far though i feel
the strongest connection to you
damn it white
why would you say something so lame to a
girl
so not men really heard of a neon is
such an affliction
you're not messing with me are you i
have no reason to lie to you
is that so
[Music]
i can't believe god himself decided to
bless me with the thing i love most
a completely clueless boy this isn't fun
for me you know well it is for me
we could have been lovers in life and
you'd be none the wiser
were we i could know every last one of
your
measurements all right
be serious here we've got a long bow
right ahead how does he even know that
fill me in you don't know how much
character
or even your relationship to me
i don't know why honestly
it's probably easier this way siblings
for both of us it's just very it's a
very complicated sibling relationship
[Music]
what yeah
definitely assisted dude you need to
chill the [ __ ] out and so does she but
she remembers it so it's it's more on
her board the ship to central heaven
stragglers will be returned to oblivion
yes don't think i made it this far last
time
this really is my first rodeo i'm not
half bad is that what what are the whole
voices it's easier for me to focus on
demon slaying without memories of past
transgressions weighing me down yeah
sure yeah we're really true then
why is it that the fire that propels me
to win feels a whole lot like guilt
heaven straight up confirmed i'm messed
up
that's why i'm a neon isn't it
surely you knew
yellow violet and red how many people do
know yeah i think probably a lot of bad
people think they're good people know me
more than i know myself
looks like demons aren't the only things
i gotta watch out for
not bad for a dead guy huh
some very persona vibes there
heaven is
exactly what i expected i do kind of
want to see it
i'll leave it on it i'm
so disappointed i should stop because
otherwise i'll just keep playing uh so
obviously this is
neon white that's the name of the game
i'm now confused because i know it's the
character
um very fun to play like the those
actual
gameplay moments are really fun and i
think that the idea of going back and
doing levels to get the gold or to find
the pathways and and um
get through them faster is very fun
because it's super intuitive very simple
controls it's super unique uh i don't
think i love the story stuff
um but i'm interested in the premise so
they definitely got me there just like
some of the characters were a little bit
over the top
um but some people like that too so
this is neon right everybody thank you
for watching i'll see you guys next time